okay welcome to the championship round
of the xxx National Geographic be out of
2.6 million students 50 for the
country's brightest young geographers
made it here to washington d.c the top
10 earned their place to compete today
and now we're down to two 13 year-old
vane cut Ranjan from california and 13
year old anushka buddha coat from new
jersey
congratulations to you both on making it
this far
[Applause]
so vane cut what would it mean to you to
win this thing I would be good be good
you've sort of underplaying it right now
right maybe I get it okay Anushka
how long have you prepared for this
moment I've been in participating in the
National Geographic Bee since I was in
fourth grade since you were fourth grade
about eight nine or ten years eight or
nine years old right you know well
excellent okay well you've come a long
way both of you and now it's time to get
down to business here's how it's going
to work you each begin this final round
with a clean slate the championship
round is single elimination you will
both be asked the same question at the
same time the contestant who correctly
answers a question that the other
contestant misses will be named our
national champion so watch closely
because every question could be the
winning question you're going to need
your stylus for this final round I will
read each question twice so listen
carefully before answering you'll then
have 12 seconds to write your responses
for the final time students are you
ready they're ready here is your
question name the small Southeast Asian
country that has a northern coastline on
the wait are and owned by straits
I repeat name the small Southeast Asian
country that has a northern coastline on
the wait are and owned by straits
thank um what do you have East Timor
Anushka Timor Leste the correct answer
is Timor Leste also East Timor so you
are both correct and we like variety
okay on to the next question
Lebanon has a population most similar to
which South American country I repeat
Lebanon has a population most similar to
which South American country
then cut what do you have Paraguay
anushka guyana do you have two different
answers i can tell you now that one is
correct so we're about to learn who is
the 2018 National Geographic Bee
champion the correct answer is Paraguay
so bangkok Ranjan is the 2018 National
Geographic Bee
please people submit
and another round of applause while we
reset for the medal ceremony
[Applause]
well done